ahora es una carrera de tres caballos en
la batalla para suceder a boris johnson
como primer ministro de reino unido el
ex ministro de finanzas risk y sunat
encabezó la última votación de los
diputados conservadores para elegir a un
nuevo líder la candidata más arriesgada
que me van eenoo que fue eliminada cargo
va de nok 59 votos
gordon 92 votos zoom a 119 votos tras 86
votos experts una cag a nado cada ronda
de votación hasta ahora y es probable
que vaya a la segunda vuelta la
selección de los dos candidatos
preferidos se decidirá en una nueva
votación el miércoles el proceso de
votación cambiará entonces de los
diputados tories a los miembros del
partido conservador la carrera para
acompañarle en la segunda vuelta se ha
apretado con la ministra de asuntos
exteriores listas superando en cinco
votos a la ministra de comercio penín
morton tras espera que la ala derecha
del partido apoye la salida de balón la
última encuesta de yougov sugiere que es
una perdería por un amplio margen frente
a atrás con un 35 por ciento de apoyos
54% detrás esa encuesta también sugiere
que more than ganar y así llegar a la
segunda vuelta consum acc obteniendo el
37 por ciento frente a 51 por ciento de
morgan la carrera ha sido divisiva y
viendo al partido gobernante dañando aún
más su administración la cosa es segura
el 5 de septiembre reino unido tendrá su
primer asiático británico o su tercera
mujer primera ministra